with almost 500 sessions at next 2019
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't see
building sustainability into our
infrastructure your goals and new
products then stay tuned because here's
the rewind you might be familiar with
Google's commitment to organizing the
world's information and making it useful
and accessible but few know about
Google's equally aggressive goals around
sustainability for example Google is
using machine learning to protect wind
power up to 36 hours in advance turning
it into a financially viable renewable
energy source that helps power our data
centers in fact Google data centers are
carbon neutral meaning that anyone who's
using Google cloud is contributing
toward their own company's
sustainability targets so let's take a
look at two of those companies and see
how they're partnering with Google to
supercharge those efforts national
geographic partners seeks to inspire
users to care about and advocate for our
sustainability with their content in
keeping with their efforts to be
environmentally conscious they moved
over their entire image collection to
Google cloud in their talk the VP of
digital products and e-commerce goes
into detail about how they plan to
expand this initiative Sun power makes
the world's most efficient solar cells
and panels for commercial and
residential use they're even used by
Google's Project loon because solar
power design is a complicated process it
would take them a century to roll out
Sun power to all American businesses and
homes but with Google Sun Room Maps data
and Google cloud machine learning Sun
power is launching a program that can
create the same design quote in only 60
seconds these and other sustainability
efforts have led to some incredible
achievements that support our planet and
we're excited to pass them down to our
customers if you'd like to see the full
talk and learn more about environmental
programs I mentioned check out the link
in the description below and don't
forget to subscribe to the cloud YouTube
channel for more great next rewind
content thanks for watching
[Music]